今天我們來聊一個真的會讓人覺得「銷售怎麼可能這樣做」的案例。一個連續創業家，他居然可以在一小時內，賣出價值 140 萬美元的產品。這數字我一看就覺得很出乎意料。
一小時 140 萬美元？這聽起來有點誇張了。怎麼說呢，一般公司要達成這樣的銷售額，可能要花上好幾個月甚至一年吧。他具體是賣了什麼？怎麼辦到的？
他叫 Alvaro Gellings，原文提到他在 2021 年推出一個時尚品牌 Ama Studios。當時他跟德國兩位非常受歡迎的線上名人合作，結果上市第一小時就賣出 120 萬歐元，換算下來大概是 140 萬美元。
等等，這裡我有疑問。找名人合作這不稀奇吧？很多品牌都會找網紅或明星代言啊，但好像很少看到能達到這種爆發性銷售的。他的「秘密武器」到底是什麼？
其實他的秘密武器，原文揭露是「創作者主導的發布模式」。Gellings 之前是做遊戲公司，很習慣買廣告來導流量、賣產品。但後來他遇到一位 Twitch 創作者，那人直接跟他說：「你要買流量，但我自己就有流量。」
嗯，聽起來這個差異點很關鍵。意思是，他發現創作者不只是代言的「媒體管道」，而是可以直接主導整個品牌敘事的「引擎」？
對，就是這個意思。他從單純「買流量」變成「擁有流量」。而且原文有提到，他跟這些創作者的合作，不是單純給錢代言，而是讓創作者參與更深，甚至成為品牌核心的一部分。
這點其實不容易做到。很多創業者或主管可能會覺得，我付錢給網紅，他幫我發文就夠了。但如果要深入到「主導品牌」，那創作者的個人形象和品牌之間的連結就變得非常重要，甚至要有點像是共同創辦人？
沒錯。Gellings 的想法是，尤其像服飾這種消費者沒有「急切需求」的商品，你光靠產品好是不夠的。你需要「創造一個故事」。他後來在 2024 年又跟一位德國耐力型運動員 Arda Saatçi 合作，成立運動服飾公司 Day One。
運動服飾就更難賣了，市場競爭超級激烈。你說故事，但故事要怎麼轉化成實際的銷售額？這聽起來很虛。
他對 Saatçi 的提案很有趣。 Saatçi 當時只有十萬追蹤者，不算頂級大咖，但 Gellings 看到他的潛力，覺得他是個「超級明星」。他給 Saatçi 的提案不是錢，而是「能見度」。
能見度？怎麼說呢？就是讓 Saatçi 更紅？但一般人喜歡錢勝過名氣吧？
原文寫到，Gellings 觀察到，跟創作者、網紅、名人接觸後發現，他們喜歡的「比錢更多」的東西，就是「受眾和流量，以及變得更有名」。所以他向 Saatçi 提出一個「極端的計畫」。
極端的計畫？是什麼？
讓 Saatçi 從柏林跑到紐約，然後團隊全程紀錄，拍成一系列長影片，再把這些精華片段分散到 TikTok 和 Instagram 上。這就是為他量身打造的超大型「故事」。
哇，這就很有意思了。這已經不是單純的產品行銷，而是一種結合了內容創作、極限挑戰和個人品牌打造的綜合行銷手法。透過一個宏大的敘事，把商品融入其中。
對。這故事本身就非常吸睛，還能累積大量有機流量，同時也讓創作者獲得了他最渴望的「能見度」。這樣一來，創作者就更有動力去「主導」這個品牌，而不只是被動代言。
如果我是創業者或主管，我從中學到的是，行銷預算不一定只能用來買廣告。它可以投資在一個能創造巨大關注的「故事」上，而且這個故事要能跟產品和創作者高度結合。
我猜啦，很多中小企業可能覺得自己沒辦法做這麼大的企劃。但我覺得概念是相通的，也許我們能思考，有沒有辦法跟「在地」或「小眾」的創作者深度合作，共同創造一個能引發共鳴的故事？
關於成本，這種極端的企劃，初期投入應該也不少吧？但相對的，它換來的巨大流量和話題性，可能比單純買廣告更划算，而且效果持久？
原文沒有提到具體成本數字，但我認為這模式的確是將行銷從「單次付費」轉向「長期內容累積」和「品牌資產建立」。而且這個故事，還能持續發酵，為品牌帶來長尾效應。
那一般上班族呢？這個概念能帶入工作或生活嗎？
嗯，我覺得或許可以換個角度想。如果我們手上有個專案或任務，與其只是「做完」或「被動執行」，有沒有可能去「創造一個故事」，讓它更有能見度，更能引起大家的關注和參與？
比如說，公司內部推一個新制度，不再只是發個公告，而是設計一個「挑戰」，讓大家一起來參與，並分享過程？
對，就是這種感覺。把「推廣」變成「共同創造」。這樣也可能讓任務的執行更有趣、更有成效。
我覺得這個案例提醒我們，很多時候我們把銷售或行銷看得太狹隘了，總覺得只有那些老方法。但其實跳脫框架，把目標從「買流量」變成「創造關注」，或許能找到不一樣的路。
好像也提醒了我們，有時候，給予合作夥伴「影響力」和「能見度」，比單純給錢，更能激發出驚人的能量。